this desert wasteland in southern
madagascar was once arable
and fertile but years of drought mean
only a few patches of green remain
the lack of water has destroyed crops
and sandstorms cover whatever's left
in a layer of dust the food here has
nearly run out
many families are forced to eat insects
or leaves to survive
in the morning i prepare this plate of
insects i clean them up as best
i can given there's almost no water my
children and i have been eating this
plant every day for eight months
because we have nothing else to eat and
no rain to allow us to harvest
what we have sown aid groups are warning
of catastrophe
especially for children like these two
now orphans after their mother died of
hunger
their arms are wasting away while their
stomachs are bloated by malnutrition
i rely on god today we have absolutely
nothing to eat except cactus leaves that
we are trying to clean up
we have nothing left their mother is
dead and my husband is dead
what do you want me to say our life is
all about looking for cactus leaves
again and again to survive
madagascar's southern region is the
epicenter of the crisis
more than a million people about half of
the area's population
need food aid and the coronavirus
pandemic has made everything worse
slowing the delivery of much-needed
supplies
many of these women and children have
walked for hours to get help
we're facing the worst drought in over
40
years and this is an area where people
depend on
their own agriculture homegrown school
meals
small holder farmers this is how they
live down here but with drought
back to back to back people can't
survive and so
the government partnering with the world
food program and others we're doing the
best we can
but it's a terrible situation [ __ ]
rains during this year's planting season
suggest
yet another harvest will fail the un's
food agency says the world must act
now or a generation could be lost to
famine
alexia o'brien al jazeera